[موسيقى]
الى تونس التي تعيش حراكا سياسيا
واجتماعيا ونقابيا على ضوء حمله اعتقالات
تطال رموز المعارضه حيث انطلقت اليوم وسط
العاصمه تونس مظاهره احتجاجيه تنظمها جبهه
الخلاص المعارضه للمطالبه باطلاق سراح
المعتقلين السياسيين
من اجتياز الحواجز الامنيه التي وضعتها
الشرطه امام طرق المؤديه لشارع الحبيب
بورقيبه رفع المتظاهرون شعارات تدعو الى
اسقاط ما يصفونه بالانقلاب واحترام حقوق
الانسان وتندد بالاوضاع المعيشيه في
البلاد وفقدان المواد الاساسيه وغلاء
الاسعار وكان والي العاصمه قد رفض السماح
بتنظيم المظاهره التي تاتي بعد يوم واحد
من مسيره احتجاجيه نظمها الاتحاد التونسي
للشغل
يا محمد
على كل هذه طبعا صور مباشره تاتينا من
العاصمه التونسيه
وكما تشاهدون هذه صور للمظاهره التي
تنظمها جبهه الفلاس وكما ذكرنا هي تاتي
بعد يوم واحد ايضا من مسيره احتجاجيه
نظمها الاتحاد التونسي للشغل